if you try to design a free way in which
some superior Authority told you where
to start where to go exactly how I'm
going to speed up and when to slow down
all of that you'd have nothing but
traffic accidents
I'm Steven Cox I'm professor of
literature at UC San Diego and I'm also
the director of the humanities program
at ravel college at UC San Diego I'm
editor of Liberty magazine which for the
past few months has been an online
publication although for 23 years before
then we were print publication my
literary interests have a lot to do with
what individual people can create as
they face literary political economic
problems I'm interested in following
individuals as they go from page to page
exploiting their material as fully as
they can in their own way it was
exciting to me in the 1990s to do
research on Isabel Patterson who was a
great libertarian figure and also a
substantial novelist and a very
important literary critic in the 20s 30s
and 40s in my biography of Isabel
Patterson which is called the woman and
the dynamo is about Patterson and the
idea of America my libertarian interests
and my literary interests really came
together I think of Patterson as the
person who first put together the little
constellation of ideas though we think
of as libertarian well Herr major worked
about economics and politics is the god
of the machine published in 1943 and
that's an exposition of how capitalism
works and why it should be allowed to
work its relations with individual
freedom and rights and a broad spectrum
and it offers a very individual idea of
how history works she is what you could
call a supporter minimal government she
is not an anarchist she believes in the
minimal state and I think most
libertarians do believe in a minimal
state and she devotes a lot of time to
how minimal the state ought to be
my book the big house image and reality
of the American prison started with my
experiences as a boy growing up seven
miles north of what was then the largest
walled prison in the world as it
advertised itself probably the study of
prisons gifts can give you wonderful
insights into human life I really shows
you something about what institutions
are and one of the insights that
libertarians going to take home about
that is that when you study prisons you
see how very hard it is to boss people
around successfully over a long period
of time and to just get things to run
according to your own views because they
have ways of resisting that you just
cannot comprehend the plan Society
prisons in the 1920s and 30s especially
we're justified specifically as planned
welfare states they their propaganda
often referred to them as the ultimate
welfare state so here's the ultimate
welfare state and how well does it run
almost always it runs in an embarrassing
ly embarrassing the inefficient
ineffective a bad way of according to
any one sense of values because it's
just that hard to plan people's lives
and to run them even on the level of a
prison which may have 3,000 or 4,000 men
in it to plan their lives and to make
sure that just on a minimal level they
do what you wanted to have them do
almost impossible our society is very
largely a spontaneous order where you
see this for instance when you're
driving down the freeway now I despite
the fact that you you realize there may
be an accident something may go wrong it
almost never does even though there are
plenty of idiots and morons out there
driving on in the same road with you and
you are often distracted and they're
distracted still you find a spontaneous
order there's certain number of rules
but they don't determine where you have
to drive they don't
you know any details at all you know you
almost always get to your destination
and so do the other people in society
because you know spontaneously how to
work with other people if you try to
design a freeway in with some superior
Authority told you where to start where
to go exactly how according to speed up
and when to slow down all of that you'd
have nothing but traffic accidents and
prisons are almost always nothing to
traffic
well Liberty magazine was founded by RW
Bradford bill bradford and his idea of
Liberty magazine was that would be
amazing for libertarians not an outreach
magazine that was trying to convert
people to a political orientation but it
was a place for libertarians to get
together to debate issues to address
problems that might not occur to anyone
picks up libertarians and generally to
meet one another so she would have
people from all sorts of fields that
weren't limited by specialized interest
we've always had a lot of college
professors writing for Liberty magazine
but it hasn't been a specialized
magazine for college professors on the
other hand it's not it's never been a
magazine there was anything other than
an intellectual magazine so it's not
something you said well read Liberty
magazine this will show you about
libertarianism well you know show you
something about libertarianism but we've
always tried to present the best writing
that we could find by libertarians or
about any issue that had or any subject
that had anything to do with personal
freedom well that's a lot so you could
probably write on almost any subject and
find a place in Liberty magazine and
Liberty continued as a print journal
until well just six months ago until
December the 2010 when we decided that
we would join the online revolution and
reach out to people who get their news
and opinions and and because their have
the opportunity to review other people's
opinions online rather than in print it
is quite a wrenching transformation for
us from Liberty magazine on the stands
to Liberty unbound calm where you can go
to find usually daily postings of
articles it's hard to define exactly
what we are we want good writing from
individual
and we are a libertarian magazine but
what people do with it whether they take
it to the polls with them yes and vote
according to the recommendations of our
authors well that's another matter
I think there are plenty of reasons to
be optimistic about the future one thing
I don't believe you get any place in
life in any way unless you're optimistic
if you assume things are going to work
out badly well then you're just helping
them to work out badly human history is
not predictable because it's what
results from individual choices and if
there's anything true about libertarian
ideas about economics that's what it is
that you can't plan a society and you
can't plan a future we'll see what
happens but I think it's the job of
libertarians to enable people to
understand that they can make better
choices economically socially
politically if they think about making
them themselves rather than referring
them to a government agency that will
give them more grounds of optimism about
the future of the country and their own
future now we know that we have
structural problems that are not likely
to go away immediately a government
spends so much of people's resources and
is so used to doing that and so many
people employed doing that and have an
interest in maintaining the status quo
is going to be very difficult to reduce
the size of government and yet we see
that the size of government has been
reduced in American history in many
dramatic and many and many important
though those smaller ways and you know
this we don't give up you know if you
want individual freedom you look to find
what you can do about it maybe you can
you can promote individual freedom in a
small way in your neighborhood maybe you
can be an important spokesman for some
national issue or maybe you can just
vote for somebody who favored smaller
government I'll try it it works